it was a bizarre scene in a region where
controversy on the football pitch is not
uncommon
five minutes after the world cup
qualifier kicked off brazilian health
officials came on to the pitch
total confusion many of the world's best
players including argentina's leo messi
and brazil's neymar had never seen
anything like it the officials said four
argentine players had given false
information about their covid 19 status
three of them were on the pitch at the
time and shortly afterwards the world
cup qualifier was suspended the players
returned to their hotels the few fans
allowed into the sao paulo stadium
drifted home angry and confused
[Music]
the health officials did the right thing
because of the coronavirus problem that
we have in this country and the world is
also facing we cannot hesitate it was
not our fault it's the player's fault
who did not comply with the quarantine
it's an awkward situation the official
should have removed the players before
they arrived at the stadium they
shouldn't have let him be on the team
it's the law but it's very hypocritical
i think there are much things than this
and the authorities do nothing
brazilian coveted 19 regulations state
that anyone entering the country who's
been in the united kingdom in the
preceding 14 days was quarantined for 14
days
four of the argentine squad play in the
english premier league nine brazilian
players in the same league stayed in the
uk
the argentine manager leonol scaloni
said no one had told him anything the
argentine football association said it
had complied with the protocol approved
by all the south american footballing
authorities
the match between these two
long-standing rivals came just two
months after argentina beat brazil in
rio de janeiro to win the regional
copper america tournament
and just two days before brazil
celebrates its independence day when
thousands are expected to march in
support of president jar bolsonaro
he's attracted widespread criticism for
his handling of the pandemic the
coronavirus has killed 583 000
brazilians and infected 21 million one
of the worst records in the world
however the football amid widespread
criticism had continued
until now
daniel schweiner al jazeera buenos aires